O of n where n is the number of elements and then you're gonna have to store like a min heap right yeah so it's actually it's actually gonna be like O of n log k I think uh because like you can't just store the top k values you have to store them in such a way that you're able to pop off Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 187, recorded on June 11th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue our chat about implementing the TopK algorithm, a.k.a. nth element in parallel. Did you listen to my last message that I sent you yet? Yes, I did. So I guess we just released episode 185, right? And that was phone tag.
O of n，其中 n 是元素数量，然后你得存储一个最小堆，对吧？是的，所以实际上它应该是 O of n log k，我想是这样，因为你不能只存储前 k 个值，你必须以一种能够弹出它们的方式来存储。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 187 期，录制于 2024 年 6 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 继续讨论并行实现 TopK 算法，也就是第 n 个元素。你听我上次发给你的消息了吗？听了。所以我猜我们刚刚发布了第 185 期，对吧？那是关于“电话标签”（phone tag）的那期。
Yeah. And then the Friday that we released, which is a couple days ago now because it's Tuesday, you recorded half of a phone tag. I did listen to that, but I've been so crazy busy for like the last three days or whatever since Friday. I have yet to act. It's been more than the last three days, buddy. Three or four days. You wouldn't even – yeah, it's been nuts. And so to answer your question, yes, I have listened to it, but no, I have not recorded my half to that. Well, you're going to have also heard my half that has not yet been recorded as of this recording.
是的。然后我们发布的那个周五，也就是几天前，因为今天是周二，你录了一半的“电话标签”。我确实听了，但过去三天左右，也就是从周五开始，我忙得不可开交。我还没来得及采取行动。伙计，已经不止三天了。三四天了。你甚至不会——是的，太疯狂了。所以回答你的问题，是的，我听了，但没有，我还没录我那部分。好吧，你也会听到我那部分，在这次录音时还没录制。
But by the time the listener has heard this, all of the recordings and publishings will have happened. So where else have you been? Because you've been like on the road, right? Oh, not really. I mean, I've been stopping back in toronto so i was at first i was at uh a craft conf it's a conference in budapest hungary that was just a two-day conference phenomenal conference um really cool because i got to meet i think you've probably met
但当听众听到这期节目时，所有的录制和发布工作都已经完成了。那你还去了哪里？因为你一直在路上，对吧？哦，也不全是。我是说，我中途回了多伦多，所以起初我是在匈牙利布达佩斯的 Craft Conf，那是一个为期两天的会议，非常棒的会议。嗯，真的很酷，因为我见到了，我想你可能见过……
kevlin henny a bunch of times because you've gone to accu yeah he's cool but i've actually never and he's one of my favorite speakers i've I've never actually met him in person. You know who we should have on the podcast. You know who I bet would be hilarious on the podcast. Oh, man. That's – why haven't – Yeah, that guy is such a good storyteller. My brain is not working right. I'm on like three hours of sleep after a lot of travel.
Kevlin Henney 好多次了，因为你去过 ACCU。是的，他很酷，但我其实从来没见过他，他是我的偶像之一，我从来没在现实中见过他。你知道我们应该请谁来播客吗？你知道我敢打赌谁在播客上会很有趣吗？哦，天哪。那是——为什么还没——是的，那家伙太会讲故事了。我的大脑没在工作。长途跋涉后我只睡了三个小时。
So bear with me, listeners, over the next two episodes here. But, yes, we should definitely have him on. He said one of my favorite things in a couple of his talks. He actually said it in one of his talks at CraftConf, which I think it was entitled Testing with Guts, G-U-T-S, Good Unit Tests. And I heard this for the first time, and he basically basically said it really bothers me when people say it's just semantics and immediately i was like absolutely oh my god this i've been thinking this like my whole life finally do people do people say yeah and it's like think about what you're saying it's it's only i've never heard the meaning of the words like it's like what are we talking about
所以接下来的两期节目请多包涵，听众们。但是，是的，我们绝对应该请他来。他在他的几次演讲中说了我最喜欢的一些话。他实际上在 Craft Conf 的一次演讲中提到了，我想题目是《Testing with Guts》（有胆量的测试，G-U-T-S，好的单元测试）。我第一次听到这个，他基本上说，当人们说“这只是语义问题”时，我真的很困扰。我立刻就想，绝对是这样，天哪，我这辈子都在想这个。终于，人们会说……是的，这就像是想想你在说什么，这只是……我从来没听过这些词的意思，就像我们在谈论什么？
i did have a conversation and i i suspect it was one of my co-workers and if the co-worker is listening i apologize in advance but i was having some conversation with somebody where they kept saying semantics but they meant syntax oh um it like it wasn't like an extended thing but it was like over the course like two minutes they said something like they said something in the effect of like well it's just semantics andantics. And I'm like, wait, I think you mean it's just syntax. Yeah. I've never heard people say it's just semantics. Oh, no, people say it.
我确实进行了一次对话，我怀疑那是我的同事之一，如果那位同事在听，我提前道歉。但我当时和某人谈话，他们一直说“语义”（semantics），但他们指的是“语法”（syntax）。哦，嗯，这并不是什么长篇大论，但在两分钟的时间里，他们说了类似“嗯，这只是语义问题”之类的话。我说，等等，我想你指的是“这只是语法问题”。是的。我从来没听过人们说“这只是语义问题”。哦，不，人们会这么说。
Semantics are all that it is. That's exactly the point. It's like... I think that it is a phrase that comes from non-programmer speak, right? Like I can think outside of the context of programming like the phrase it's just semantics is like a common phrase which kind of means like it's just details right yeah and so people might be saying that to mean it's just details whereas i think i i don't
语义就是一切。这正是重点。这就像……我认为这是一个来自非程序员口语的短语，对吧？就像我可以跳出编程的语境来思考，“这只是语义问题”是一个常见的短语，意思大概是“这只是细节”，对吧？是的，所以人们可能会用它来表示“这只是细节”，而我认为我……
know i'm a spec i'm like a programming language spec person so so so maybe maybe i have a warped perspective on this but i think most programmers will would not would interpret that differently but i think it's just a common phrase in like the english language in general yeah and i think it's similar to when it's like a different way of saying tomato tomato which i also take issue with yeah because nobody says tomato like tomato your program has undefined behavior it's a motto and uh anyways we'll we'll definitely get kevlin on i think he'd be a blast to chat with and then after that i was at should i should i email him what you want me to email him yeah sure you can email him right now. Like before we forget. Yeah.
不知道，我是个编程语言规范方面的人，所以也许我的视角有点扭曲，但我认为大多数程序员不会那样解读。但我认为这只是英语中一个通用的短语。是的，我觉得这类似于“番茄，番茄”（tomato, tomato）的另一种说法，我也对此有异议。是的，因为没人会说“番茄”（tomato）像“番茄”（tomato）。你的程序有未定义的行为，它是“番茄”（a motto）。无论如何，我们一定会请 Kevlin 来，我觉得和他聊天会很有趣。然后在那之后，我是在……我应该给他发邮件吗？你想要我给他发邮件吗？是的，当然，你现在就可以给他发。趁我们还没忘。
Yeah. Well, I mean, not like right now, but I'll start the draft of the email. Sounds good. You heard it here first, folks. ADSP, probably before episode 200, we'll have Kevlin on. See, but the problem now is that like if he rejects us, you're going to have to cut all this out. No, no, no. I mean, it's a bad look.
是的。嗯，我是说，不是现在马上，但我会开始起草邮件。听起来不错。各位，你们先听到了。ADSP，大概在第 200 期之前，我们会请到 Kevlin。看，但现在的问题是，如果他拒绝我们，你就得把这些都剪掉。不，不，不。我是说，这看起来很糟糕。
It's a bad look because we're i'm i'm a big fan you know so uh i i have a follow-up for one of our past episodes uh where we talked about uh top k algorithms we talked about um uh radix partitioning and uh i mentioned that i was chatting with my our co-worker elias um and he wrote me on Slack. And he said, maybe one remark on why an LSD Radix partitioning pass doesn't work. An LSD partitioning pass tells you nothing about the final rank of an item because you're just looking at the least significant part. This partitioning pass is only helpful to resolve ties between items that compare equal on all the more significant digits.
这看起来很糟糕，因为我是他的大粉丝，你知道的。所以，我有一个关于我们过去节目的后续，我们讨论了 Top K 算法，我们讨论了基数分区（radix partitioning），我提到我正在和我们的同事 Elias 聊天，他在 Slack 上给我写了信息。他说，关于为什么 LSD（最低有效位）基数分区过程不起作用，有一个备注。LSD 分区过程对项目的最终排名没有任何帮助，因为你只是在看最低有效的部分。这个分区过程只有在解决那些在所有更重要位上比较相等的项目之间的平局时才有用。
At this point, you just don't know yet whether there are ties on the more significant digits because you are yet to look at those. Remember, this is why LSD radix sort requires stable partitioning passes, while the MSD doesn't, unless you want a stable sort. And then he gave an example that's going to be hard for me to verbalize. But I think that's a pretty good explanation of what we talked about. Why do we do LSD for the radix sort versus it being problematic for the radix partition? And so he writes at the bottom of his example that the MSD radix sort, however, gives you already some idea about the final ranks of an item.
在这一点上，你还不知道在更重要的位上是否有平局，因为你还没看那些位。记住，这就是为什么 LSD 基数排序需要稳定的分区过程，而 MSD（最高有效位）不需要，除非你想要稳定排序。然后他给了一个例子，我很难用语言表达出来。但我认为这是对我们所讨论内容的很好的解释。为什么我们对基数排序使用 LSD，而它对基数分区却有问题？所以他在例子的底部写道，MSD 基数排序已经给了你关于项目最终排名的一些概念。
An item won't cross the boundaries of the bucket it has been assigned to. In subsequent passes, it will just refine its position within the boundaries of its bucket. So wait, so that makes sense, but where does this leave us with respect to the top K question? Well, I think we may have talked about it on the phone tag episode, but I had suggested that it may be worth it for a Radix partitioning algorithm to do a pre-pass where you do a max. And then the max tells you how many, like what is the relevant, the most relevant digit on the most significant side. And so, like, you know, if your maximum integer is, you know, like 100, then there's a lot of digits that you can skip over, right? And so, like, in this, it depends on your cost function of how much...
一个项目不会跨越它被分配到的桶的边界。在随后的过程中，它只会细化它在桶内的位置。等等，这说得通，但关于 Top K 问题，这让我们处于什么位置？嗯，我想我们可能在“电话标签”那期讨论过，但我建议基数分区算法进行一次预处理，即求最大值。然后最大值会告诉你，比如，最相关的位在最高有效位侧是什么。所以，你知道，如果你的最大整数是 100，那么有很多位你可以跳过，对吧？所以，这取决于你的成本函数，关于多少……
Well, no, it actually doesn't, because it's not just a computational cost thing, right? It's not just the cost of doing the extra passes that are maybe not so useful. No, actually, I think it is. I guess it is. But you're also paying... I think you would pay an additional cost,
嗯，不，实际上不是，因为这不仅仅是计算成本的问题，对吧？不仅仅是做那些可能没那么有用的额外过程的成本。不，实际上，我想是的。我想是的。但你也要付出……我想你会付出额外的成本，
and the additional cost is, like if your maximum integer, if you've got like 32-bit integers and the maximum integer in the set that you're partitioning is an integer that's 100, and you do radix partitioning, starting with the most significant digit, like the first like more than half passes
额外的成本是，如果你的最大整数，如果你有 32 位整数，而你正在分区的集合中的最大整数是 100，并且你进行基数分区，从最高有效位开始，就像前一半以上的过程
is going to put everything into the first bucket. And I don't know if we do actual data movement to put things into buckets, or if we just do it with flags. But certainly, it's like a lot of wasted computation there. And depending on how expensive those passes are, it might make it might be worth doing that first max pass. So essentially you're just trying to take your sort algorithm and basically just minimize the amount of computation that you would have to do. But then what happens when you get your k is going to be in one of the bins? I'm talking specifically for partition. Oh, so just for partition
会把所有东西都放进第一个桶里。我不知道我们是否真的移动数据来把东西放进桶里，还是只用标志位。但可以肯定的是，那里浪费了很多计算。根据这些过程的昂贵程度，进行第一次最大值过程可能是值得的。所以本质上你只是试图采用你的排序算法，基本上只是最小化你必须做的计算量。但当你得到你的 k 时，它会在其中一个桶里吗？我专门指的是分区。哦，所以只是为了分区
yeah right because for as he was explaining for a radix sort like you're sort of going through everything anyways and like it's fine for the sort but for partitioning like you want
是的，对吧，因为正如他解释的那样，对于基数排序，你无论如何都要遍历所有东西，对于排序来说这没问题，但对于分区，你想要
to like split things up into reasonably sized buckets. But that's kind of like a non-deterministic algorithm, right? Based on the distribution of values, if you're looking for top K, you're going to have to continuously do that partition until you're able to determine your your kth value which for some which i guess is what you're saying so up front if you're doing some pass to get you to the maximum or some other like metadata on the distribution of your values you can then make sure that like in the worst case you're not just doing a bunch of extra work. And it is worth noting that thrust's radix sort takes bits, like an optional bit start and bit end parameter,
把东西分成大小合理的桶。但这有点像非确定性算法，对吧？基于值的分布，如果你在寻找 Top K，你将不得不持续进行该分区，直到你能够确定你的第 k 个值，我想这就是你所说的。所以，如果你预先进行一些过程来获得最大值或关于值分布的其他元数据，你就可以确保在最坏的情况下，你不会只是做一堆额外的工作。值得注意的是，Thrust 的基数排序接受位，比如可选的位开始和位结束参数，
for you to tell it what bits what uh you know bits do you want to to actually sort ignore these bits because you know they're never used yeah yeah it's still it's still kind of somewhat somewhat unsatisfying because of the like uh i don't know non-determinism of it yeah i mean it's probably it's probably better than sample sort, though. Yeah, I mean, like, it's definitely for a K value that's not sufficiently small or sufficiently large to do the either reduction or sort, it's definitely going to be better than doing a full-blown sort.
让你告诉它你想要实际排序哪些位，忽略这些位，因为你知道它们从未使用过。是的，是的，它仍然有点令人不满意，因为它的那种……我不知道，非确定性。是的，我是说，它可能比采样排序（sample sort）要好。是的，我是说，对于一个不够小或不够大的 K 值，无法进行归约或排序，它绝对比进行完整的排序要好。
Yeah. You know, what we were talking about last time with, like, the small k case, it got me thinking a little bit more that if k is small but not small enough that you would want to pass it by value. Like if k is like 10, or okay, let's use a simpler example. If k is 1, you know, it's just a max reduction. And so like it's pretty clear that you don't need any like additional overhead or anything. There's no state at all. If K is two, you need some state, right?
是的。你知道，我们上次讨论的小 K 情况，让我更多地思考，如果 K 很小，但又没小到你想按值传递它。如果 K 是 10，或者好吧，让我们用一个更简单的例子。如果 K 是 1，你知道，这只是一个最大值归约。所以很明显，你不需要任何额外的开销。根本没有状态。如果 K 是 2，你需要一些状态，对吧？
Your operator needs some state to remember what the largest was, because it's searching for the second from largest. Right. I mean, technically, max reduction also requires state, but it's just the accumulator value. So it doesn't need extra state, additional state. Yeah. And so the amount of state that you need grows linearly. And so like, if it's two, and because this is an accumulator value, you're passing this around by value. We're talking about state that gets passed around through the reduction. So it needs to be something that you're comfortable passing around by value on the stack. If it's two, you're probably comfortable with that.
你的操作符需要一些状态来记住哪个是最大的，因为它在寻找第二大的。对。我是说，技术上，最大值归约也需要状态，但它只是累加器值。所以它不需要额外的状态。是的。所以你需要的状态量是线性增长的。所以，如果是 2，而且因为这是一个累加器值，你是按值传递这个东西的。我们讨论的是通过归约传递的状态。所以它需要是你乐意在栈上按值传递的东西。如果是 2，你可能没问题。
If it's like 10,'re probably comfortable with that. If it's like 10, you know, maybe also that's fine. If it's 100, that's starting to get to be a place where that's too large. But I was thinking if the K is 100, is it possible that there's some algorithm where you have side storage of, you know, some array of 100 elements, and then you have some synchronization protocol um for uh everybody to sort of collectively update that and is that possibly faster i don't know it's an idea i mean it's very i mean it's very side effecty like the very is
如果是 10，你可能也没问题。如果是 100，那开始变得太大了。但我当时在想，如果 K 是 100，是否可能存在某种算法，你有侧存储，你知道，某个 100 个元素的数组，然后你有一些同步协议，让每个人集体更新它，这可能更快吗？我不知道，这只是个想法。我是说，这非常……我是说，这非常有副作用，非常
unnecessary it is side effecty but it could I don't know it could be faster but it could be I mean what's the what's the complexity and number of comparisons of you know a max reduction yeah I mean yeah if you know you know you have enough arguments and at a certain point... No, that was a question. What's the complexity of a max reduction? Sorry, what's the complexity of a max reduction? Like a parallel max reduction? Yeah.
不必要，它确实有副作用，但它可能……我不知道，它可能更快，但它可能……我是说，最大值归约的复杂度和比较次数是多少？是的，我是说，如果你知道你有足够的参数，在某一点……不，那是个问题。最大值归约的复杂度是多少？抱歉，最大值归约的复杂度是多少？比如并行最大值归约？对。
No, just like a max reduction in general. It's linear in time and O1 in space. Right. And like radix sort, which is the special case, radix sort is like what? It's like O, W times N, where N is the number of keys and W is the key length. So it's like kind of like linear E. But like merge sort
不，只是普通的归约。时间复杂度是线性的，空间复杂度是 O(1)。对。像基数排序，这是特殊情况，基数排序是什么？它是 O(W * N)，其中 N 是键的数量，W 是键的长度。所以它有点像线性的。但像归并排序
or for anything that can't be radix sorted, what's merge sort? Merge sort is like, you know, in login. So I guess it is better, right? Right, right, right. Radix sort is worse complexity-wise. Because the best of the... Okay, so maybe this doesn't ever make sense, right? Right, right, right. Radix sort is worse complexity-wise. Because the best of the, okay, so maybe this doesn't, this never makes sense, right? Because any form of the reduction based approach is going to be linear. And if you do something that requires synchronizing this,
或者对于任何不能进行基数排序的东西，归并排序是什么？归并排序是 N log N。所以我想它更好，对吧？对，对，对。基数排序在复杂度上更差。因为最好的……好吧，所以这可能根本没意义，对吧？因为任何形式的基于归约的方法都将是线性的。如果你做一些需要同步这个
you know, global array, that's going to probably be expensive. Radix sort is actually worse than like the best case sorting algorithms right because it's it's linear too yeah the only the only thing that changes is the the space complexity it goes from o of one to o of k what do you mean yeah so like you're definitely correct that a max a max reduction whether you are accumulating a single value a pair of values or a vector or array of k values it's always linear in time complexity yeah is that actually true i think for k actually it does change it's going to be o of n where n is the number of elements and then you're going to have to store like a min heap right yeah so it's actually
全局数组的事情，那可能会很昂贵。基数排序实际上比最好的排序算法还要差，因为它也是线性的。是的，唯一改变的是空间复杂度，它从 O(1) 变成了 O(K)。你是什么意思？是的，所以你绝对正确，最大值归约，无论你是累加单个值、一对值，还是 K 个值的向量或数组，它的时间复杂度总是线性的。这是真的吗？我想对于 K 来说，它确实会改变，它将是 O(N)，其中 N 是元素数量，然后你得存储一个最小堆，对吧？是的，所以实际上
it's actually going to be like o of n log k i think uh because like you can't just store the top k values you have to store them in such a way that you're able to pop off efficiently. So I guess the question here is, how fast of an atomic min heap or max heap can you implement? I mean, don't they already exist? This is like C++ has a priority queue isn't that just like a yeah but it needs to be it needs to be atomic oh you mean for the version where it's stored like outside of the it's not even it's actually we're not even talking about a reduction right at this point if like if you're if you're still a reduction you have side stored
它实际上会是 O(N log K)，我想是这样，因为你不能只存储前 K 个值，你必须以一种能够高效弹出它们的方式来存储。所以我想这里的问题是，你能实现多快的原子最小堆或最大堆？我是说，它们不是已经存在了吗？这就像 C++ 有优先级队列，那不就是……是的，但它需要是原子的。哦，你是说对于存储在它之外的版本？它甚至不是……我们甚至不是在谈论归约，如果……如果你仍然在进行归约，你有侧存储
i mean no it's not it's not it's not really reduction it's everybody everybody is just putting stuff into it into the queue yeah that's more of like a four each but technically you could like yeah in in non-parallel land or even in parallel land you technically could do it you're just like you're suggesting an alternative implementation where instead of storing the state in the accumulator, you're storing it outside and then having some kind of locking and synchronizing. But you technically could, in C++ non-parallel land, just accumulate a priority queue or min heap, max heap, whatever. And then I think in C++ 17, I don't fully... I remember watching Ben dean's talk uh and he they added like uh move semantics
我是说，不，它不是，它真的不是归约，每个人都只是把东西放进队列里。是的，那更像是“对每个”（for each），但技术上你可以……是的，在非并行领域，甚至在并行领域，技术上你可以做到，你只是建议一种替代实现，而不是把状态存储在累加器中，你把它存储在外面，然后进行某种锁定和同步。但技术上，在 C++ 非并行领域，你可以只累加一个优先级队列或最小堆、最大堆，随便什么。然后我想在 C++17 中，我不完全……我记得看过 Ben Dean 的演讲，他们添加了类似“移动语义”
to the accumulators so you could actually like do a reduction on a string that was doing plus equals to the string and so basically you know adding characters or strings to strings and previously that was like terrible it's better to do that in a for loop, because you're going to end up copying the string every single time if you try and do it inside of reduction. But then in C++ 17 or 20, I think they added the capability of the lambda that you're passing to your accumulator reduce, they added the ability for that to have copy elision. So technically, like, you could implement what you're talking about without storing it in like side memory or whatever you want to call it but yes the version that you're talking about i'm not sure i understood that explanation you want to try that again
到累加器，所以你实际上可以对字符串进行归约，即对字符串进行加等于，所以基本上，你知道，把字符或字符串加到字符串上，以前那太糟糕了。最好在 for 循环中做，因为如果你试图在归约内部做，你最终会每次都复制字符串。但在 C++17 或 20 中，我想他们添加了你传递给累加器 reduce 的 lambda 的能力，他们添加了它进行复制省略（copy elision）的能力。所以技术上，你可以实现你所说的，而不需要把它存储在侧内存或任何你想叫它的东西里。但是的，你说的那个版本，我不确定我是否理解了那个解释，你想再试一次吗？
so it's at some point in c++ 17 or 20 they basically added the ability for the return type of the lambda that you pass to your reduction algorithm for it to take advantage of copy elision. So like pre C++ 17 or 20, I can't remember which one it is. If you are doing a reduction on a string where your initial string is empty and you basically just want to join a bunch of strings, that was like extremely inefficient because every single time you did your your plus you would basically do a copy of your string but like they added an optimization where you can take advantage of move semantics aka copulation where now you actually can't perform a reduction on like a list
所以，在 C++17 或 20 的某个时候，他们基本上添加了你传递给归约算法的 lambda 的返回类型利用复制省略的能力。所以，在 C++17 或 20 之前，我不记得是哪一个了。如果你正在对字符串进行归约，其中你的初始字符串是空的，而你基本上只是想连接一堆字符串，那是非常低效的，因为每次你进行加法时，你基本上都会复制你的字符串。但他们添加了一个优化，你可以利用移动语义，也就是复制省略，现在你实际上可以对字符串列表进行归约来构建一个字符串，而你最终不会得到一堆副本。嗯，所以问题在于……如果你在并行做这个，有一堆副本，这……问题在于，如果你在并行做这个，就像，是的，如果你……你所说的是……
of strings to build up one string and you're not going to end up with a bunch of copies um which so here's the problem with that um if you're doing this in parallel like with a bunch of copies, which. Here's the problem with that. If you're doing this in parallel, like, yeah, it's like, if you're, what you're saying is like,
如果你做了一个串行左折叠（fold left），你可以把状态放在累加器类型中，你永远不会分配更多。对，因为你可以总是移动这个累加器对象。你永远不会进行复制。是的，对，因为你可以总是移动这个累加器对象，你永远不会进行复制。是的，问题是，我们正在获取输入序列，我们正在划分它，我们有一
if you did like a serial fold left, like you could, you could have your state in the, the accumulator type and you wouldn't ever allocate more. Right. Cause, cause you could just always move this accumulator object thing. You'd never make a copy. Yes. right because because you could just always move this accumulator object thing you'd never make a copy yes problem is that we're taking the input sequence we're dividing it up and we've got a
大堆人在并行操作。是的，是的，所以在并行中这根本行不通。是的，真正的问题实际上是……你可以某种程度上在并行中做那个，但任何形式的……我当时在想，如果你有一些侧数组，然后如果你每个线程组有一个侧数组，但你必须合并这些侧数组，那很烦人。
whole bunch of people operating in parallel yeah yeah so in parallel this doesn't work at all yeah and the the real problem actually is that uh uh like you could kind of do that in parallel but any form of like I was thinking what if you had some side array and then what if you had one side array per group of threads but then you have to merge the side arrays and then that's annoying
你可以那样做，有并行合并算法，但它很烦人，有额外的成本，这意味着本质上你最终构建了看起来非常像糟糕排序的东西。是的，实际上，在你刚才说那话之前，我真的在想，在并行算法中，当你存储 K 时，当你合并块之间的最小堆或任何东西时，你最终将不得不进行类似 std::merge 的操作，这是一种算法
you can do that there's parallel merge algorithms but it's annoying at another cost and then that means like essentially you you end up building building the the the uh something that looks a lot like a bad sort yeah actually i was while you were saying right before you said that i was literally thinking actually i in the yeah in the parallel algorithm where you store k when you are combining the the you know min heaps or whatever in between the chunks uh you're gonna end up having to do like a stood merge which is like an algorithm
我这辈子从没用过，但我知道它存在，用于合并两个排序列表。是的，是的，我的观点只是，当你刚才说这不是真正的归约时，我同意。这更像是“对每个”的副作用。是的。但理论上，你可以像我说的，在非并行 C++ 领域高效地做这种事情。是的，我想你可以。是的，我相信外面有相关的论文。
that like i've never used in my life but i know exists for like combining two sorted lists and yeah yeah yeah my my point was just that like uh when you were saying this isn't really reduction. I agree. It's more of like a for each side effect thing. Yeah. But like in theory, you could do this kind of thing efficiently in, like I said, non-parallel C++ land. Yeah, I think you could. Yeah. I'm sure there's a paper out there.
我们应该做些研究，或者我们应该让听众去做些研究。去帮我们找那篇论文。关于 Top K。关于并行 Top K。我相信这是一个足够常见的问题。外面有一堆论文。但我不知道我是否见过任何关于为小 K 进行基于归约的方法的文献，以及它是否划算，因为如果它是 10，它开始变得有趣了，因为 10 是……假设
We should do some research or we should get the listener to do some research. Go find us the paper. On top K. On parallel top K. I'm sure it's a common enough problem. There's a bunch of papers out there. But I don't know that I've seen any literature on doing a reduction-based approach for like small k and whether that pays out like because like if it's like 10 um it starts to get interesting because 10 is like if let's say
假设是 32 位数字，你知道，10 个整数携带起来相当笨重，对吧？因为 10 个整数是 40 字节。但是，想象一下按值传递它并不荒谬。所以它可能划算。这里有趣的是，对于 CPU 和 GPU，回报可能非常不同。因为对于 CPU，你会有数量级，数百个线程。所以每个线程会做更多的工作。所以你会减少累加器类型的实际复制。所以你可能以这种方式处理更大的 K。
let's assume 32-bit numbers like you know 10-inch is pretty chunky to have to to to carry around, right? Because 10-inch is, you know, 40 bytes. But, like, it's not ludicrous to imagine just passing that by value. So it might pay off. And what may be interesting here is that the payoff might be very different for CPUs versus GPUs. Because for CPUs, you're going to have order of magnitude, hundreds of threads. So each thread is going to be doing a lot more work. And so you'd have less actual copying around of your accumulator type. And so you could potentially handle a bigger K this way.
我是说，再说一次，你仍然必须进行合并。但对于 GPU，你有更多的线程，所以这只对更小的 K 有意义。是的，推入优先级队列的复杂度是多少？它是 log N，log N，其中 N 是队列的长度，对吧？对，是队列的长度。是的，我总是……当我还在面试的时候，这总是让我很恼火，当你遇到一些二次复杂度的问题，然后他们问时间复杂度是多少，然后你说哦，它是二次的，但技术上，你相乘的两个 N 实际上并不相同，它是 N 乘以 M。
I mean, again, you still have to do the merge. But for GPUspus you have a lot more threads and so you this only makes sense for much smaller k yeah what's the complexity of uh of pushing into like a priority it's log n log n where n is the length of the the q right right it's the length of q yeah i always i'd always irritated me back when i was in my interviewing days when you'd have some quadratic complexity question and then you'd they'd say what's the time complexity and then you'd say oh it's quadratic but technically like the n the two n's that you're multiplying are not actually the same it's like n by m
所以复杂度不是二次的，它是 N 乘以 M。我一直认为那只是……我是说，技术上 N 乘以 M 是正确的，但你知道，在高层面上它是二次的，你知道，你有一块数据矩形，它是二次的。但他们总是会说，哦，它不是二次的，我会说，我是说，技术上它是 N 乘以 M，但让我们进入下一个问题吧，各位。不，你知道吗，我想我错了，我想我之前说错了，我想这可能确实划算，因为归并排序是 N log N，这比 N 更差。是的，是的，绝对。我想我之前错误地说它不是。所以我认为你可以达到……好吧，不，好吧，好吧，不。因为想想看。如果你对每个元素必须做的是推入堆。
so the complexity is not quadratic it's n times m i always thought that was just i mean technically n times m is correct but you know at a high level it's quadratic you know you got uh you got a rectangle of data it's quadratic but then they'd always they'd always be oh it's not quadratic and i'd be like i mean technically it's n by m but like let's move on to the next question folks uh no you know what i think i miss i think i misspoke before i think that this does maybe pay off because merge sort is n log n which is worse than n yes yes definitely i think i said i think I mistakenly said earlier that it's not. So I think you can get to, well, no, okay, all right, no. Because think about it. If what you have to do for every element is that you have to push heap.
嗯，不，实际上，也许不是。好吧，所以如果你对每个元素必须推入一个 K 大小的堆，那么你正在对 N 个元素进行 log K 操作，这比 N log N 要好。然后你唯一的其他成本是进行合并的成本。是的，而且技术上时间复杂度是 N log K，但你并不总是会进行插入。就像时间复杂度是最坏情况，但平均而言，你可能只会进行 log K 插入。
Well, no, actually, maybe not. Okay, so if you, for every element, if you have to push into a K-sized heap, then you're doing a log K operation for n elements right which is better than than in log n and then the only other cost that you have is the cost of doing the merge yes and also too like technically the time complexity is n log k but you're not always going to be doing the insertion like Like the time complexity is the worst case, but like on average, you're probably only going to be doing the log K insertion.
我不知道，比如百分之多少的时间？是一半吗？是 20% 吗？是 10%？我们不知道。这取决于数据。在最坏的情况下，你必须每次都做，在某种反向排序或排序序列中。但在平均情况下，你会做一些检查来看看……当你……如果你在插入之前做，我想……我想也许当你实际推入它时，我不知道它是怎么运作的，所以它可能
I don't know, like a percentage of the time. Is it half? Is it 20%? Is it 10? We don't know. It depends on the data. In the worst case, you'll have to do it every time in some like whatever reverse sorted or sorted sequence. But in the average case case you're going to do some check to see is you know when you if before you do the insertion i think i think maybe when you actually push into it i don't know if that how that actually works so like it might
当你尝试插入最小堆时，它已经处理好了，如果它大于最大值或任何东西，它就会丢弃它，那是一个 O(1) 操作，对吧？所以它确实会比 N log K 更好。它会是……而且我们可能能够忽略合并的成本，即必须合并这些堆的成本。我之所以这么说，是因为涉及合并的元素数量级
already take care of it when you try to insert into a min heap and it's it's greater than the largest value or whatever it uh it'll just discard it and that's like an o1 operation right so it's greater than the largest value or whatever, it'll just discard it, and that's like an O1 operation, right? So it's really going to be better than, like, N log K. It's going to be... And we might be able to kind of ignore the cost of the merges, of having to merge these heaps together. And the reason I say that is because the order of magnitude of, like, how many merge, like, the order of magnitude of the elements involved in the merges
比输入的数量级小得多。所以它们某种程度上被摊销了。是的，我们在这个问题中假设 K 的数量级远小于 N。我们在这个问题中也假设并行执行代理的数量级远小于 N。所以即使在 GPU 上，你可能有成千上万或数十万个线程，
is much smaller than the order of magnitude of the inputs. So they're kind of amortized. Yeah, we're assuming in this problem that the order of magnitude of K is substantially smaller than N. And we're also assuming this problem, that the order of magnitude of the number of parallel execution agents is substantially smaller than N. So even on a GPU, you might have thousands or hundreds of thousands of threads,
但我认为在 GPU 上你只需要每个线程块有一个这样的堆。而 GPU 线程块会有成千上万个。是的。而且你会有，你知道，至少数百万，但很可能是数千万或数亿个输入元素。所以合并成本可能没那么昂贵。是的。好吧，我们录音到一半了。我们想结束这个话题吗？关于 Top K，
but I think that you would only need on a GPU to have one of these heaps per thread block. And GPUs, thread blocks, are going to be in the thousands. Yeah. And you would have, you know, at least millions, but probably tens of millions or hundreds of millions of input elements. And so the merge costs may not be that expensive. Yeah. All right. Well, we're at the halfway mark of the recording. Do we want to wrap up this topic? Any final thoughts on the top K,
并行 Top K 有什么最后想法吗？嗯，Elias，如果你在听，你应该去原型化这个。完美。委派工作。好吧，这就是第 187 期，如果我的编号没错的话。一定要在你的播客应用中或在 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
parallel top K? Well, Elias, if you're listening, you should go prototype this. Perfect. Delegating work. All right. That's episode 187, if I've got my numbering correct. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的口号。其实那不是口号。我们的口号是混乱中点缀着信息。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。